now a lot of seven-year-old girls a lot
of them but not all are probably into
pop bands princesses and anything pink
but not Adele raus no she's come all the
way from the United States to meet her
heroes there at the University of
Nottingham and they're the team who make
videos about the wonders of chemistry
videos which have become quite an
internet sensation
Quentin Rayner takes up her story when
you've seen it it has gone with a great
Bush periodic videos brings the flash
bang wallop of chemistry to a global
audience through the internet so far
they've been viewed over 60 million
times
seven-year-old Adele routes from North
Carolina has been hooked since the age
of four today she got to meet some of
the team who make the video welcome to
the school of chemistry you're knotting
um it's lovely to meet you made this
whole webpage it's like a periodic table
and you can click on the element and
then there's like this video coming here
and meeting all of these chemists is for
her the equivalent of going to Disney
World and meeting all of the Disney
Princesses for the rest of her female
classmates might still be a bit big for
you after being presented with her own
laboratory coat
Adele got the chance to watch one of her
favorite experiments mixing water and
ether with potassium so we need one more
thing to add in there one more
ingredient it's a water because you've
got the ether in there it gives us the
big flame I've seen this on the Internet
I've watched these videos many many
times I just watch these videos over and
over and over again what's it like to
actually be here in the lab where they
make them ah
it's beyond our wildest dreams we never
expected that people would watch online
videos and think I've been moved so much
by than that I want to travel all this
way and see and greet and interact with
the people who've made these videos when
she's grown into her lab coat Adele
wants to either be a scientist or a
mathematician
Quentin Rana BBC's Midlands today
Nottingham
what a star you are Adele if you're
watching certainly are